WHETHER HE'S LIKELY TO GET
THROWN OUT OF COURT OR PERHAPS
LAUGHED AT.
>>> A LOT HAPPENING TONIGHT.
WE BEGIN WITH THE ASSASSINATION
OF HAITI'S PRESIDENT.
IT WOULD BE A SHATTERING
DEVELOPMENT.
HAITI AS YOU KNOW AND AS WE'VE
REPORTED HAS HAD MORE OF ITS
SHARE OF MISFORTUNE, WHETHER
FROM POVERTY, POLITICAL VIOLENCE
AND IT SEEMS INTRIGUE.
FOOTAGE FROM MOMENTS AROUND THE
KILLING.
YOU'LL NOT SEE ANY IMAGES ON THE
CLIPS THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO PLAY
YOU.
THE FRAME IS BLACK.
WHAT YOU'LL HEAR IS CERTAINLY
RAISING QUESTIONS.
WE'VE EDITED THE SAME PASSAGE
TOGETHER SEVERAL TIMES OF
SOMEONE CLAIMING TO BE FROM THE
AMERICAN DEA, THE DRUG
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, SO YOU CAN
HEAR MORE CLEARLY WHAT'S BEING
SAID.
>> EVERYBODY BACK UP, STAND
DOWN.
EVERYBODY STAND DOWN.
DEA OPERATIONS, EVERYBODY BACK
UP, STAND DOWN.
DEA OPERATIONS, EVERYBODY STAND
DOWN.
DEA OPERATIONS, EVERYBODY BACK
UP, STAND DOWN.
>> SO, AGAIN, WE REPEATED THAT
SO YOU COULD HEAR MORE CLEARLY.
AGAIN, WE CANNOT INDEPENDENTLY
AUTHENTICATE THIS.
THE DEA DENIED ANY INVOLVEMENT.
WHATEVER THE CLIP IS, IT DOES
SEEM TO BE PART OF THE PICTURE
OR TO BE MORE PRECISE, PART OF
THE PUZZLE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
HAITI LAST NIGHT.
MORE NOW FROM CNN'S MELISSA
BELL.
>> Reporter: BY THE TIME
SECURITY FORCES RESPONDED IN THE
EARLY HOURS OF WEDNESDAY
MORNING, IT WAS TOO LATE.
HAITIAN PRESIDENT WAS DEAD
ASSASSINATED IN HIS PRIVATE
RESIDENCE.
HIS WIFE, THE FIRST LADY OF
HAITI, GRAVELY WOUNDED,
MEDIVACED TO THE U.S. FOR
POTENTIAL LIFE-SAVING TREATMENT.
AS DAYLIGHT DAWNED ON THE
AFTERMATH OF BULLET HOLES AND
SPENT SHELL CASINGS, THE SCOPE
OF THE BRAZEN ATTACK MORE CLEAR.
>> Translator: THE INFORMATION
WE HAVE IS THAT THE ATTACKERS
WERE A GROUP OF ENGLISH AND
SPANISH-SPEAKING PERSONS.
THEY WERE CARRYING HUGE CALIBER
WEAPONS AND KILLED THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Reporter: THIS AUDIO
PURPORTED TO BE OF THE TIME OF
THE ASSASSINATION.
CNN CANNOT CONFIRM THE
AUTHENTICITY OF THE VIDEO.
MEN SHOUTING IN ENGLISH.
>> DEA OPERATIONS, EVERYBODY
BACK DOWN, STAND DOWN.
>> Reporter: CLAIMING THEY ARE
U.S. DRUG ENFORCEMENT AGENTS
PROVIDING CLUES OF HOW THE
ATTACKERS MAY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PENETRATE THE SECURITY PERIMETER
SURROUNDING THE PRESIDENTIAL
RESIDENCE SEEMINGLY WITH EASE.
THE AMBASSADOR TO THE U.S.
SAYING THOSE RESPONSIBLE ARE
SAID TO BE HIGHLY TRAINED
MERCENARIES POSING AS U.S.
OFFICERS.
>> THEY PRESENTED AS DEA?
>> YES, THEY PRESENTED
THEMSELVES AS DEA AGENTS.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THEY WERE
ACTUALLY DEA?
>> NO.
THERE WAS NO WAY.
NO WAY DEA WOULD HAVE COME.
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN INFORMED AND
EVERYTHING.
>> Reporter: THE U.S. STATE
DEPARTMENT ALSO DISMISSING AS
PREPOSTEROUS THAT THOSE
RESPONSIBLE COULD BE DEA AGENTS.
>> THESE REPORTS ARE ABSOLUTELY
FALSE.
THE UNITED STATES CONDEMNS THIS
HEINOUS ACT.
THESE FALSE REPORTS ARE NOTHING
MORE THAN THAT, JUST FALSE
REPORTS.
>> Reporter: THE HAITIAN
GOVERNMENT SAYS A MANHUNT IS
UNDERWAY FOR THOSE RESPONSIBLE.
THEY ASSUMED LEADERSHIP OF THE
COUNTRY TRYING TO ASSURE A
STUNNED POPULATION AS WELL AS
WORLD LEADERS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT OF HAITI IS STILL
FUNCTIONING DECLARING A STATE OF
SIEGE WHICH ALLOWS FOR THE
CLOSING OF NATIONAL BORDERS AND
TEMPORARILY INVOKE MARTIAL LAW.
>> WE WANT TO ENSURE YOU WE WILL
BRING THE KILLERS OF THE
PRESIDENT TO JUSTICE.
PLEASE STAY CALM AND LET THE
AUTHORITIES DO THEIR WORK.
WE DON'T WANT THE COUNTRY TO
PLUNGE INTO CHAOS.
THIS IS A VERY SAD DAY FOR OUR
NATION AND FOR OUR PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: IN LIFE HAITIAN
PRESIDENT WAS A POLARIZING
FIGURE WITH MANY PROTESTING HIS
RULE AND DEMANDING HE RESIGN.
HE PRESIDED OVER A COUNTRY ON
THE PRECIPICE OF CHAOS.
THE QUESTION NOW, WILL HIS DEATH
PUSH THE NATION PAST ITS
BREAKING POINT.
MELISSA BELL, CNN.
>> JOINING US NOW FROM HAITI IS
FREELANCE JOURNALIST HAROLD
ISAAC.
WHAT IS IT FIRST LIKE IN HAITI
TONIGHT?
WHAT'S THE SCENE LIKE?
>> Reporter: WELL, ANDERSON, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT EMPTY STREETS.
BUSINESSES ARE CLOSING.
BEEN CLOSED ALL DAY.
THERE'S STILL A MASSIVE SENSE OF
SHOCK AFTER WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
EARLY HOURS OF TODAY AND YOU
HAVE A NATION TRYING TO REEL
WITH THAT NEW REALITY.
>> WHAT WAS THE SECURITY LIKE AT
THE PRESIDENT'S HOUSE?
HE WAS, ACCORDING TO REPORTS,
ASSASSINATED AROUND 1:30 IN THE
MORNING TODAY.
CAN YOU JUST TALK ABOUT WHAT
THAT COMPOUND IS LIKE AND HOW
DIFFICULT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN TO
GET IN?
>> Reporter: WELL, ANDERSON, AS
YOU'VE BEEN TO HAITI IN THE
PAST, SINCE 2010 THE NATIONAL
PALACE HAS BEEN DESTROYED AND
HAS NOT BEEN REBUILT SO
PRESIDENTS HAVE TAKEN A HABIT OF
NOT ACTUALLY LIVING IN A
NATIONAL PALACE WHERE THEY WOULD
NORMALLY HAVE BEEN.
SO THE HOUSE OF PRESIDENT MOISE
WAS HIS RESIDENCE.
IT MAKES IT MORE STUNNING THAT
SUCH A THING WOULD HAPPEN IN
SUCH A SECURE LOCATION.
>> THE IDEA THAT THEY WERE
YELLING OUT DEA CLAIMING THEY
WERE PART OF THE DEA IN A
COUNTRY LIKE HAITI, THAT'S
ACTUALLY PROBABLY A PRETTY
EFFECTIVE THING FOR THEM TO HAVE
DONE, ISN'T IT?
OBVIOUSLY THE U.S. HAS ENORMOUS
POWER IN HAITI.
IN SOME OTHER COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD IF SOMEBODY YELLED OUT
DEA OPERATION, IT MAY NOT HAVE
ANY IMPACT.
IN HAITI, PEOPLE WOULD PROBABLY
LISTEN TO THAT, WOULDN'T THEY?
>> Reporter: WELL, THIS WAS
SHOCKING AND IT WAS A BIG SENSE
OF AWE, ESPECIALLY AT THE TIME
IT HAPPENED.
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO LOOKED
VERY ORGANIZED, VERY STRUCTURED,
VERY PROFESSIONAL, AT LEAST FROM
THE VIDEOS GOING ONLINE COULD
CARRY THAT SENTIMENT AND COULD
BE IMPRESSIVE.
HOWEVER, YOU ALSO HAVE THE
SECURITY UNIT OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE REPUBLIC, WHICH IS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST TRAINED ELITE CORE
IN THE POLICE TO HAVE BEEN
TRAINED IN THE U.S. AND
ELSEWHERE.
THEY'RE THE BEST PAID AND
THEY'RE TRAINED AND THEY KNOW
THEIR DRILL.
IT'S HIGHLY QUESTIONABLE THAT
THEY WOULD FALL FOR A TRAP LIKE
THAT.
>> AND OBVIOUSLY THE AIRPORT WAS
SHUT DOWN AS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND
AS WELL AS THE BORDER WITH THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
SO WHOEVER DID THIS MOST LIKELY,
I ASSUME, WOULD STILL BE IN THE
COUNTRY.
ARE YOU HEARING ANYTHING ABOUT
WHAT AUTHORITIES ARE TRYING TO
DO TO TRACK THEM DOWN?
>> WELL, THE PRIME MINISTER SAID
IT IN HIS PRESSER AND ALSO IN
THE STEPS HE'S BEEN ANNOUNCING
AND THE DECREES, THAT THE
INVESTIGATION IS ONGOING AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO FIND THE
PERPETRATORS.
BUT HE'S UNCLEAR, ACTUALLY.
THE SITUATION IS STILL VERY
UNCLEAR AND THAT'S PART OF THE
REASON WHY EVERYBODY'S HUNKERING
DOWN BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
DO WE EXPECT FROM THIS NEW
REALITY AND WHAT'S DONING ON THE
COUNTRY.
>> THE ACTING PRIME MINISTER HAS
DECLARED A STATE OF SIEGE IN
HAITI.
ARE YOU CLEAR ON WHAT THAT
ACTUALLY MEANS?
>> WELL, ANDERSON, A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ASKING ACTUALLY
WHAT THAT ACTUALLY MEANS.
IT'S UNPRECEDENTED IN OUR RECENT
HISTORY THAT SUCH A MEASURE HAS
BEEN TAKEN, BUT FOR I GUESS THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, THE WAY I COULD
EXPLAIN IT, IT'S AKIN OF MARTIAL
LAW.
THAT MEANS ALL PUBLIC LIBERTIES
ARE SUSPENDED.
VIRTUALLY ANYONE CAN GET
ARRESTED FOR ANY REASON AND
HOUSE CAN BE SEARCHED WITHOUT
WARRANTS.
THESE ARE THE KIND OF MEASURES
WE'RE LOOKING AT IN THE COMING
HOURS OR DAYS IN ORDER TO
RESPON